well boris johnson's resignation has
cast doubt over what aspects of his
government's agenda will live on and now
one mayor has called on conservative mps
vying to be the party's next party
leader and prime minister to fully
commit to leveling up in red wall and
left behind areas joining us now teas
rally mayor that's ben hutchins hello to
mr hajj and thanks for joining us on the
programme what do you want to hear from
these candidates
well this morning i've written to the
leadership contenders because we're
talking a lot about tax cuts there's
obviously an internal battle within the
conservative party for the next leader
but what we're not hearing is what
they're going to do and whether they're
going to recommit to leveling up that
was a key policy of the boris johnson
government it's one of the things that
led to many people voting conservative
for the first time ever
it obviously started to build what is
that that trendy term the red wall
and i've asked that there are a minimum
number of principles that these
leadership contenders sign up to to make
sure that this fantastic policy and
something that's actually really needed
to bring the rest of the uk together
that they they sign up to these minimum
number of principles actually like i say
as a minimum i hope they can go further
and develop a very strong leveling up
policy but at the moment we're not
hearing anything from any of the
contenders and i would hope that mps
before they vote on wednesday will be
asking these questions because there are
many of those mps that have their seat
because of the level of policy that
boris johnson championed
who are you looking at who's taking your
fancy at the
well at moment
moment nobody's replied to the letter
and my concern at the minute is making
sure that largely the north but also
other parts of left behind areas across
the country are fully supported i think
the leveling of gender is agenda is
absolutely key to achieving that and
i'll be deciding on who i support
depending on the responses and who gives
the uh the best responses to develop
that policy and taking like i say areas
like mine in t-side have been left
behind for many many decades what is a
new prime minister going to do to be
able to support an area like ours not
just t side but across the whole of the
north of england and as i said when
there was this whole debacle going on
about whether we should get rid of
the prime minister boris johnson or not
my concern is this agenda could be on
the back burner and like i said over the
last few days all we've heard about is
tax cuts and they're extremely important
and i'm sure that people will make their
mind up about that but there is much
more to running a government than just
tax cuts and i think the leveling up
agenda is something that will define the
next general election
i'm guessing you also want the final two
candidates to come up to the region and
talk to the local people there
absolutely um and i agree with many
people who've said that what we actually
need to make sure is that this isn't
just the coronation what we can't have
is a stitch up between the final two
candidates and then the members and the
wider um the wider country can't see
what the two candidates have to offer
and as we did when boris johnson was
selected as prime minister there should
be a number of hustings across the
country people should be able to form
their views before deciding on who the
new prime minister's going to be
okay um just do you prime minister
should the new prime minister be a
northerner
um i'm less concerned about where
they're from i mean
prime minister boris johnson is not from
the north of england but is arguably one
of the biggest champions of the north of
england for many many decades it depends
on the policy of the person like i said
in the letter that i've written i want
to see people i want to see sorry the
contender who is successful commit to
keeping a secretary of state responsible
for levelling up i want to see them uh
commit to more devolution for other
parts of uh england and potentially
parts of the uk as well because it's
been hugely successful in places like
t-side i want more powers to existing
mayors i would say that one night being
a mayor uh in england i also want the
government to commit to really important
uh
large infrastructure projects which i
think send a huge statement to
communities and the public across the uk
like northern powerhouse rail i think we
need to go further and we need to get
eastward's connectivity across the north
as being much much stronger um so
there's a huge amount that needs to be
done
and i hope that whoever is successful
commits to that agenda that's going to
be largely deciding where my support
goes and whether they come from oaks
bridge whether they come from central
london or whether they come from
middlesbrough it doesn't matter as long
as they've got the right policies for
the
country
um just before i let you go we're almost
out of time if boris johnson could stand
again
would you vote for him
i'm hugely sad and disappointed that
this prime minister's going i've always
been a huge supporter it's no um it's no
there's no way from getting away from
that um i think he's done a huge amount
for the north of england i think start
in a really interesting agenda i think
he's attracted people to politics and to
vote for the conservatives that would
never have considered voting for us
before and it's fair to say that under
this prime minister my area that i
represent has done extremely well so
it's a sad day um when i see this prime
is to go and hopefully
the next prime minister will be able to
do as much as they can to fill his boots
and you know that's yet to be seen